uh we have seen over the last four years
decade 15 years
almost pic pick your time frame
um
much of the american right wing
riddled with projection projection where
they claim the left is doing that which
they are actually doing so one example
is the right loves to say we are for
free speech and the left is against free
speech and in reality it's often the
truth that the right is for free speech
only in their very narrow view for as
long as it's convenient to them and then
they are very quickly against it they
don't care about free speech once it's
no longer convenient to them
social media regulation is a great
example of this as soon as the lion's
share of covet disinformation is coming
from the right they're no longer okay
letting twitter or youtube or facebook
decide what's okay on their platform
they want to
uh mandate that these platforms allow
covid disinformation now on the other
side of that they claim to be against
business regulation they're that's a
principle we are against regulating
businesses until twitter is banning the
people they want to ban from twitter and
all of a sudden they say we need to
regulate twitter to force them to allow
certain speech you guys understand this
concept the principle is abandoned as
soon as it's inconvenient so along these
lines there's this topic of of books and
banning books and they claim the left
wants to ban books that are inconvenient
to them
that being said i've heard nothing about
wanting to ban bobby kennedy junior's
anti-vaccine anti-doctor fouchy book
or whatever other book what what we want
and speaking for myself
i want
to educate people
so they never fall for buying these dumb
books in the first place but this is not
about me
because now there's a rash of right
wingers
wanting to ban and in some cases
succeeding at banning all sorts of books
from all over the place often under the
guise of protecting kids that's the
explanation that they will often give a
few examples of this a tennessee school
board has voted unanimously to ban the
pulitzer prize-winning book mouse this
is about the holocaust in cartoon form
some of you emailed me about this they
want to ban it from their eighth grade
curriculum they say it has objectionable
language and nudity cartoon nudity of
course and there's similar campaigns
underway in all sorts of other uh
districts in more than 30 states at this
point stateline has been investigating
this and they will often say these books
are pornographic
merely because they depict an lgbtq
experience
sometimes a black character with an
lgbtq experience a huffington post huff
post now it's called reports that in
texas the republican governor greg
abbott
is
sort of taking advantage of this effort
to pull quote pornographic or obscene
books from school libraries after
republican representative matt krauss
circulated a list of 800 books that he
believes crosses the line and the vast
majority of these books were written by
women or people of color or lgbtq
writers according to the dallas morning
news so consider how many of their own
supposed principles they are violating
here they are for free speech
but they've got a long list of books
that they want to ban
they are for doing what's best for
people yet they're not letting education
experts the teachers decide is this book
a good teaching tool for my students or
not they are deciding from above the
elected officials that is and the
reasons that they give for banning most
of these books should actually apply to
the bible but of course the bible is
always okay
murder in the bible incest genocide
sexual content it's all in the bible but
the bible is beyond reproach that's a
sacred cow
so putting all of this aside
a great way to get kids interested in a
lot of these books is to ban them i mean
i i'm against the book banning on
principle of course
but i also recognize that banning these
books might get kids interested in in
the books as well
the urge to do something you're not
supposed to do
can sort of end up being like an adrenal
adrenaline rush but that being said
uh many of these books can easily be
read online but it is again an example
of it it's really one of the major
stories of conservatives it's not even
conservatism of reactionary right
thinking of the last era of this era
which is our prince nothing is more
important than our principles of course
our principles are sacred
until the outcome of those principles is
inconvenient when it comes to speech
when it comes to censorship when it
comes to regulation when it comes to
elections at the end of the day and this
is just the latest example let me know
if this is going on in your state in
your locality you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping